hi I'm dr. Scarlett Howard I'm a
postdoctoral research fellow at the
University of Toulouse I'm a scientist
working on the cognitive abilities of
honeybees I have been specializing in
the past for the past four years on the
ability of bees to learn numbers and use
number to solve problem learn complex
numerical concepts and that sort of
thing so I've been able to show that
honeybees can add and subtract and they
can value numbers along a number line
to train bees to add and subtract we
train them to fly into a why misshaped
apparatus when they flew in davis or a
number it could have been three dots for
example then if those dots were blue the
B learned to add if they were yellow the
be learned to subtract by one each time
so when the bee flew in if she saw three
blue dots she'd then fly into another
chamber where she see two options and if
that was one more then the number she'd
seen before so if we saw three and it
was blue she should go to four if she
saw three and it was yellow she should
go to two and so over the course of a
hundred learning events the bee got a
reward of sugar water for choosing
correctly and she tasted a bitter
substance when she chose incorrectly as
she came back from hive over and over
again she slowed learnt addition and
subtraction over a hundred trials
the honeybee has a brain which is has
less than a million neurons compared to
our brains which have about 100 billion
and so being able to look at the brain
which is a relatively small and simple
brain gives us a lot of insight into
things such as how to build better
artificial intelligence how to make
computer processing more powerful and it
can even tell us a lot about our own
evolution and the ability of our own
brains
studying the numerical abilities of
Bay's does tell us a lot about human
mathematical ability today and that's
because while we share a common ancestor
over 600 million years ago with Bayes
seeing that both humans and bees have
similar levels of numerical ability and
can do similar tasks while we're a lot
more sophisticated than the Bayes and
our abilities it means that we probably
have a common ancestor 600 million years
ago that had these numerical processing
skills and I find that really
interesting